Mike was out with his dog. It was a January night. He was on the C&O Canal in Washington DC. I've been there. It's like you're in the city, but it feels like you're in the woods. On one side of you is the Potomac River. On the other side there's this pretty old canal, which was frozen over that night. He gets around three miles out in his jog and stops to stretch. His dog, Looly, is off leash.
迈克当时正带着他的狗在外面。那是一个一月的夜晚。他当时在华盛顿特区的切萨皮克和俄亥俄运河边。我去过那里。那里给人的感觉就像身处城市，但又仿佛置身树林。你的一侧是波托马克河。另一侧是那条很漂亮的老运河，那天晚上运河已经结冰了。他慢跑了大约三英里，停下来做伸展运动。他的狗Looly没有系绳。
And so I remember throwing a stick down near the water, just seeing if she'd go after it. And I started stretching. And I'm getting my calves. And I'm looking toward the Potomac, so I'm not really paying attention to her.
我记得当时把一根棍子扔向水边，只是想看看它会不会去追。然后我开始做伸展运动。我在拉伸小腿肌肉。我的目光朝向波托马克河那边，所以并没有怎么注意它。
I turned around. Couldn't have been more than 30, 40 seconds. And she's in the middle of the canal, probably 30, 35 feet out there.
我转过身。时间肯定不超过30到40秒。它已经在运河中央了，离岸边大概有30到35英尺远。
She's standing on the ice, you mean?
你是说它站在冰上？
She's standing on the ice, and she's sniffing around. And I go, Looly, Looly, get back here. And she puts her head up. And it couldn't have been more than three seconds later I just heard this sploosh. And she goes through.
它站在冰面上，正在四处嗅探。我喊道：“Looly，Looly，快回来。”它抬起头。仅仅过了不到三秒钟，我就听到了“扑通”一声。它掉下去了。
And I'm freaking out. [LAUGHING] And I all of a sudden, OK, OK, she'll get out of this. She's a dog, they can contort out of anything. And she started trying to get her paws up on the ice. And they just kept slipping off. And she was kicking it like crazy from behind.
我吓坏了。（笑声）我突然想，好吧，没事的，它会自己爬出来的。它是一条狗，它们什么都能钻出来。它开始试图把爪子搭在冰面上。但爪子一直在打滑。它还在后面拼命地蹬腿。
And a good minute goes by. And now I'm sort of trying to coax her out gently, like Looly, come on. Come on, baby. Come on, girl. Come on.
足足过去了一分钟。我现在试图温和地哄它出来，比如，“Looly，过来。过来，宝贝。过来，小姑娘。快过来。”
And a minute goes by. And I'm starting to think, OK, this is not good. And then two minutes go by. And she's starting to whimper, these little-- [WHIMPERING] And I'm going, oh, man.
又过去了一分钟。我开始觉得，情况不妙。接着两分钟过去了。它开始呜咽，发出那种细小的……（呜咽声）我心想，天哪。
And I'm looking around. There's nobody around. It's pitch dark. I only remember even two people on the trail running that I even saw.
我环顾四周。周围一个人也没有。四周漆黑一片。我记得在跑道上甚至只看到过两个人。
Today's show is about how do you choose what to do. How do you decide your move in a daunting situation where stakes are high? Like Mike, he's got no rope. His dog is too far out to use a branch or something. There's no time to get help. So what's he do?
今天的节目主题是当你该如何抉择。在形势严峻、风险极高的情况下，你如何决定自己的行动？就像迈克，他没有绳子。他的狗离得太远，没法用树枝之类的东西。没时间去求援了。那么他该怎么做？
I literally thought about some Discovery Channel thing I'd watched once. And the guy was showing you, if you never want to fall through ice, how to distribute your body weight, if you put this much here and this much here.
我当时脑海里真的浮现出曾经看过的某个探索频道的节目。那个人在演示，如果你不想掉进冰窟窿，如何分配身体重量，如果你在这一点放多少力，那一点放多少力。
You mean you spread your body out, like you're lying on the ice? Is that how?
你的意思是把自己平摊开，就像趴在冰面上那样？是那样吗？
Right. Right. I put my arms out and my legs, like I'm almost splayed. And I'm slowly moving across it.
对。对。我伸出双臂和双腿，就像大字型趴着一样。然后慢慢地在上面移动。
And you're on your stomach?
你是趴在肚子上吗？
I'm on my back. I'm on my back.
我是仰面朝天。我是仰面朝天的。
He thinks, OK, worst case scenario, if the ice breaks-- well, he had actually jumped into the canal once. And he's 6' 4". The water only came up to his chest. So again, worst case, he could still grab the dog and walk out.
他想，好吧，最坏的情况，如果冰破了——其实他有一次跳进过运河。他身高6英尺4英寸。水深只到他的胸口。所以，最坏的情况，他还是能抓住狗走出来。
We're talking the canal here. We're not talking the Colorado River. And it was the classic miscalculation because I started to move out to her-- and I wasn't that far from her. I can't remember, maybe 10, 15 feet.
我们说的是运河。我们不是在说科罗拉多河。但这绝对是一次经典的误判，因为我开始朝它移动——我离它并不远。我不记得了，大概15英尺吧。
And she's looking at me. And she's in kind of a little ice hole. And she's trying to get toward me. And in my head, I just had this sort of weird thought that I hadn't thought of before. My dog is about 65 pounds. I'm about 205 pounds, 210 at that point.
它看着我。它身处一个小冰洞里。它正试图向我靠近。我脑子里突然冒出一个以前没想过的奇怪念头。我的狗大约65磅重。我当时大约205或210磅。
What if the chip-- boosh, I go right through. I fell through the ice myself. And the shocking thing was, I'm tasting sulfur. I'm tasting the sediment of the thing. And I can't stand.
万一冰……轰的一声，我直接掉下去了。我自己掉进了冰窟窿。最令人震惊的是，我尝到了硫磺味。我尝到了那里的沉积物味道。我站不起来了。
Mike was a sportswriter for The Washington Post when all this happened years ago. And he wrote a really beautiful account of what came next for the newspaper. And as part of that, he researched-- and yeah, the center of the C&O Canal does get much deeper than 6' 4".
多年前这一切发生时，迈克还是《华盛顿邮报》的体育记者。他为报纸写了一篇非常优美的后续报道。作为报道的一部分，他做了一些调查——是的，切萨皮克和俄亥俄运河的中心确实比6英尺4英寸深得多。
So he's in the water. He's only about five feet away from his dog. He wrote that plunging into the icy water, the moment that happened, the water shocked him like a dental drill hitting an exposed nerve.
所以他掉进了水里。离他的狗只有大约五英尺远。他写道，掉进冰冷的水中，那一刻，水的冲击就像牙钻钻进暴露的神经一样。
That's what it felt like. Boom, it was freezing.
感觉就是那样。砰，冷极了。
And then one of the things that's very arresting about reading your account of this is just how fast things go south for you. It's like you're trying to pull yourself up on the ice. And then right within two minutes, you can't even feel your hands. And your lower extremities are beginning to feel numb. The dog is in even worse shape than you.
读你的这段描述最触动人的地方在于，你的情况恶化得太快了。就像你试图把身体撑到冰面上。两分钟内，你的手就已经没知觉了。下肢开始麻木。你的狗比你更糟糕。
Yeah. She's just looking toward me for help. But every time I try to push myself up on the ice, it cracks a little. I can't get on a solid piece. And I'm starting to get cuts on my wrists as I'm going up on the ice. And I'm probably panicking at that point a little too because I don't have much time. These things happen quickly.
是的。它只是看着我寻求帮助。但每次我试图把自己撑上冰面，冰就会裂开。我找不到一块坚硬的地方。当我向上撑时，手腕被冰割破了。那时我也有些惊慌失措，因为我没多少时间了。这些事情发生得很快。
He tried over and over to lurch himself up under the ice. But every time he did, it would break underneath him, and he'd be back in the water. He made it to his dog Looly. She put her paws on his back to hold herself up.
他一次又一次地试图挣扎着爬上冰面。但每次尝试，脚下的冰都会破裂，他又掉回水里。他终于够到了Looly。它把爪子搭在他的背上来支撑自己。
It wasn't clear what to do. He thought about the stories you always hear, about people who die in the wilderness hiking or whatever. There's a cameraman from The Washington Post newsroom who he'd known named John.
他不知道该怎么办。他想起了总是听到的那些故事，关于在荒野徒步时死去的人之类的。《华盛顿邮报》新闻编辑室有个摄像师，他认识，叫约翰。
He was a kayaker, biggest, strongest guy I ever saw in the newsroom. He died in a kayak accident because the water pinned him under in West Virginia somewhere. And we had this big funeral for him. And I just thought of all those stories.
他是个皮划艇运动员，是我在新闻室见过最高大、最强壮的人。他在西弗吉尼亚州的某处发生皮划艇事故，被困在水下淹死了。我们为他举行了盛大的葬礼。我当时想到了所有这些故事。
And I had this really selfish, vain moment where I thought, I'm not dying in the Kodiak region. I'm not dying in the Gallatin or the Madison in Montana. I'm friggin' 15 minutes from a Ralph Lauren store and a Five Guys. Georgetown's down the street.
我当时有一个非常自私、虚荣的念头，我想，我不能死在科迪亚克地区。我不能死在蒙大拿州的加拉廷或麦迪逊河。我离拉尔夫·劳伦专卖店和Five Guys汉堡店只有15分钟路程。乔治城就在街下。
My main thing was I didn't have a lot of time. I didn't know how much time I was in there, but literally, my legs were starting to freeze up. And so at that point, the only thing I could think of was, I can't get up here on my own. And she looks worse off than me. And so I took my right arm and put it under her like a big fishing hook.
我主要担心的是我没多少时间了。我不知道自己在水里泡了多久，但我的腿真的开始冻僵了。就在那一刻，我唯一能想到的是，我自己爬不上去了。它看起来比我还糟。于是，我伸出右手像个大鱼钩一样伸到它身下。
And then with all of his strength, he heaved Looly up onto the ice. She scampered to the bank, shook herself off, ran down the trail, then realized he wasn't with her, and came back. Now she kept a safe distance on the shore. He thought to himself, who's going to find his dog when he's gone? Who's going to take care of her?
然后，他用尽全身力气，把Looly甩到了冰面上。它跑到岸边，抖了抖身子，顺着小径跑开，然后意识到主人没跟上来，又跑了回来。现在它在岸上保持着安全的距离。他心想，如果他死了，谁会发现他的狗？谁会照顾它？
It was quiet. He could hear cars in the distance. This moment, he wrote about it. And I asked him to read it for us.
四周很安静。他能听到远处汽车的声音。这一刻，他写了下来。我请他为我们读一读。
"I had been in the freezing water for about three minutes, I figured. I half remembered reading an article that said hypothermia could set in between four and seven minutes. I drew in deep breaths and paused maybe 10 seconds. I figured I had one minute, maybe two with physical exertion left. I felt nothing in my hands and arms, which just slid off the ice each time I tried to pull myself up.
“我估计自己已经在冰冷的水里待了大约三分钟。我隐约记得读过一篇文章说，体温过低可能在四到七分钟内就会发生。我深吸几口气，停顿了大约10秒钟。我估计自己只剩下一分钟，也许两分钟的体力了。我的手和手臂已经毫无知觉，每次试图爬上冰面都会滑落。
I wanted to believe there was an internal survival mechanism that would kick in, an uber human force that would enable me to rescue myself. But losing muscular function prevents those surreal endings. I began to consider my options and arrived at a plan I should have thought of before I went in after her."
我想要相信有一种内在的生存机制会启动，一种超人的力量能让我自救。但肌肉功能的丧失阻止了那种奇迹般的结局。我开始考虑其他选择，并想到了一个我早该在跳下水救它之前就想到的计划。”
The plan? He called for help, loud as he could. Screamed, and waited for a while. Nothing.
什么计划？他尽可能大声地呼救。尖叫，然后等了一会儿。什么也没有。
"Suddenly I didn't feel cold or frozen. And that, I would learn later, meant I was heading into stage two of hypothermia. I remember leaning my elbows on the ice for balance and looking at Looly pacing along the bank."
“突然，我不觉得冷了，也不觉得冻僵了。后来我才知道，这意味着我正在进入第二阶段的体温过低。我记得我把手肘撑在冰面上保持平衡，看着Looly沿着岸边徘徊。”
And then a guy showed up, a law student who'd been out for a jog. He sees Mike. And his opening line is, hey, so what are you doing in the ice? The way he gets Mike out is that he wades into the cold water, breaking the ice as he walks forward, his feet solidly on the ground, never getting in too deep. And then Mike breaks the ice and kind of lurches towards him.
然后一个路人出现了，一个出来慢跑的法律系学生。他看到了迈克。他的第一句话是，嘿，你在这冰水里干什么呢？他把迈克救出来的方法是走进冷水中，边走边踩碎冰面，脚稳稳地踩在地面上，从来没有陷入太深。然后迈克也踩碎冰面，摇摇晃晃地向他挪过去。
So we're probably about 15 feet from each other. And I just kept lunging and lunging. And I got a couple of feet more. And all of a sudden, I could feel my feet touch the bottom. And it was at that moment, I was like, oh, my god, I'm freezing, but I'm going to get out of here.
所以我们当时大概相距15英尺。我一直在猛冲，不停地猛冲。我多挪了几英尺。突然，我感觉到脚底碰到了地面。就在那一刻，我想，天哪，我冷极了，但我能活着出去了。
The student's name is Jason Coates, who's still in regular touch today over a decade later. Over that time, Mike's thought a lot about that night in the canal when he nearly died.
那个学生名叫杰森·科茨，十多年后的今天我们还保持着联系。这些年来，迈克经常想起那个差点让他丧命的运河之夜。
In hindsight, do you think you made the wrong calculation and the wrong choice trying to save your dog?
回想起来，你认为试图救你的狗是不是一个错误的计算和错误的决定？
I made the wrong calculation when I took her leash off along a frozen canal.
当我沿着冰封的运河把它的绳子解开时，我做出了错误的计算。
I know, but the real choice that endangered your life was to decide to go rescue her. In retrospect, do you think, well, that was just the wrong choice? I should not have tried to rescue her.
我知道，但那个真正让你生命陷入危险的选择是决定去救它。回想起来，你认为，好吧，那纯粹是个错误的决定吗？我不该去救它的。
No. I don't think I made the wrong choice. Because--
不。我不认为我做出了错误的选择。因为——
Wow.
哇。
--a life without her-- the next 10 years wouldn't have been a life worth living.
——没有它的生活……接下来的10年将是不值得活下去的人生。
No. Come on. Really?
不。别这样。真的吗？
I mean that sincerely.
我是真诚的。
You almost died. You're just lucky that somebody was passing by.
你差点死了。你只是走运碰巧有人路过。
It doesn't matter. That dog was everything to me.
那不重要。那条狗对我来说就是一切。
Now, you're married now.
现在，你已经结婚了。
Yeah.
是的。
When you've told your wife this story, does she agree with that assessment, do you think, that you should have gone in? Like is this an example to her of something about your judgment?
当你告诉妻子这个故事时，你觉得她认同你的评估吗，就是你应该跳下去？比如，这对她来说是不是一个关于你判断力的例子？
[LAUGHING] Oh, she has 10 other examples of bad judgment. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, there's definitely, as my wife says, Señor Drama. OK, Señor Drama, take it easy. And so, yeah, I definitely lead with my heart.
（笑声）哦，她有另外10个例子证明我判断力糟糕。是的，是的，是的。正如我妻子所说，那是“戏剧之王”。好吧，戏剧之王，冷静点。所以，是的，我确实是个跟着感觉走的人。
Well, today on our radio show, we have stories like this one of people in difficult situations trying, basically, to scramble their way up onto the ice and having to invent how to do it, trying one thing after another. That kind of battle, it brings out who you really are. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天在我们的电台节目中，我们有类似的故事，讲述人们在困难的情况下，试图挣扎着爬上冰面，不得不发明出解决办法，尝试了一个又一个方法。那种战斗，展现了你真正的自我。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, New Sheriffs in Town. So the House of Representatives, of course, is where the Democrats are now in the majority. And they are flexing their muscles. Take the Michael Cohen hearing that just happened. If Republicans are still in charge of the House, do you think that could have ever happened?
第一幕，城里的新警长。众议院，当然，现在民主党占多数。他们正在展示自己的实力。就拿最近发生的迈克尔·科恩听证会来说。如果是共和党仍然控制众议院，你认为那种事可能发生吗？
We're in for lots more hearings like that. And if you believe the news, the Mueller report about what the president did and did not do is apparently maybe close to being done. When that comes out, it'll probably mean hearings, about whether it's going to be released to the public, about whatever it is that it says.
我们还将迎来更多这样的听证会。如果你相信新闻，关于总统做了什么和没做什么的穆勒报告，看来可能快要完成了。当它发布时，可能会引发一系列听证会，关于是否向公众披露，以及关于报告里的任何内容。
And a lot of that is probably going to happen in the House Judiciary Committee. Now, that's a different committee from the one that did the Cohen hearings. Our producer Zoe Chace spent weeks with the Judiciary Committee as they prepared for their very first oversight hearing. It happened a few weeks ago. And she watched them during this first hearing, trying to exercise the new power that they got when they took the majority, the power to drag in whoever they want and grill them with questions before the cameras.
其中很多可能会发生在众议院司法委员会。这与举行科恩听证会的委员会不同。我们的制作人佐伊·蔡斯在司法委员会准备他们的第一次监督听证会时，和他们待了几个星期。这发生在几周前。在第一次听证会上，她观察他们试图行使他们在获得多数席位后得到的新权力，即传唤任何人并当着摄像机的面盘问他们的权力。
As we hear, it was not a cakewalk. The Democrats had to fight for every step, adjust tactics, try this and that. Here's Zoe.
正如我们听到的，这不是一件容易的事。民主党必须为每一步而战，调整策略，尝试这尝试那。下面是佐伊。
The House Judiciary Committee has its own hearing room-- long gold drapes, rich blue carpet. And the way the room is set up, everywhere you look is a reminder of exactly who's in power and who is out. The C-Span cameras are set up stage left so the Congress people and the majority are shot at the best angle. They just look better on TV. The minority staffers have to squeeze awkwardly behind the cameras just to get up to their members on the dais. It's not dignified.
众议院司法委员会拥有自己的听证室——长长的金色窗帘，深蓝色的地毯。房间的布置，无论你看向哪里，都在提醒着到底谁掌握权力，谁被排除在外。C-SPAN的摄像机架在舞台左侧，这样国会议员和多数党在镜头里呈现出最好的角度。他们在电视上看起来更好。少数党的职员不得不尴尬地挤在摄像机后面，才能走到议事台上的议员身边。这太不体面了。
The majority has a much bigger staff. It controls the budget. Even the portraits on the wall of the past chairmen that look down on everything, even those are arranged so that the majority's portrait gets the benefit of that better camera angle. You know who knows every inch of this room, including even the parts behind the scenes that the mortals never see? Jerry Nadler.
多数党有更大的职员团队。它控制预算。甚至墙上俯瞰一切的历任主席的画像，就连那些画像的摆放也是为了让多数党的主席画像能享受到更好的摄像角度。你知道谁了解这个房间的每一寸吗，甚至是凡人从未见过的后台部分？杰里·纳德勒。
There's a door to the right, to the right of the committee room doors.
右边有一扇门，在委员会大厅门的右侧。
Nadler is the new chairman of the House Judiciary Committee.
纳德勒是众议院司法委员会的新任主席。
You walk in that door, that's the minority staff room. And you'll see a narrow corridor, two very small bathrooms, an office, a little space for a printer or for a microwave.
你走进那扇门，就是少数党员工室。你会看到一条狭窄的走廊，两间非常小的洗手间，一间办公室，还有放打印机或微波炉的一小块空间。
A printer or a microwave, that really sums up the choices the minority gets. It's where Nadler's been for the last eight years, but no longer.
打印机或微波炉，这真的总结了少数党能做的选择。那是纳德勒过去八年待的地方，但现在不再是了。
Now walk in on the other side of the committee room, and you won't see that little thing. You see a suite of eight, or nine, or 10 offices.
现在走进委员会大厅的另一边，你不会看到那种小东西。你会看到一间有八、九或十个办公室的套房。
A suite-- nice, big offices with couches and extra chairs for big staff meetings. The point is, the switch is always extreme. Right now, it's an especially big deal.
套房——漂亮、宽敞的办公室，配有沙发和额外的椅子，用于大型员工会议。关键在于，这种切换总是很极端的。目前，这是一件特别重大的事情。
The House leadership has made clear they're going to push back against President Trump. They're passing bills. They're running oversight hearings and investigations.
众议院领导层明确表示他们将反击特朗普总统。他们正在通过法案。他们正在进行监督听证会和调查。
Nadler's committee, the Judiciary Committee, is looking for the answer to the very slow motion movie we've been watching since President Trump took office. Did the president abuse his power? Did the president obstruct justice? Hanging over that question, for Nadler, is the possibility of impeachment, because impeachment proceedings, if they ever happened, would start in the Judiciary Committee.
纳德勒的委员会，司法委员会，正在寻找我们自特朗普总统上任以来一直在观看的那部极其缓慢的电影的答案。总统是否滥用了权力？总统是否妨碍了司法公正？对于纳德勒来说，悬在那个问题之上的是弹劾的可能性，因为弹劾程序如果发生，将从司法委员会开始。
But for now, it's just hearings, hearings for days, hearings as far as the eye can see. And for every hearing that makes the news that rises like a bubble to the surface where we can see it, there is this churn underneath of meetings and pre-meetings and strategy sessions. That's the work I'm here to see.
但目前，只是听证会，没完没了的听证会。对于每一次登上新闻头条、像气泡一样浮出水面被我们看到的听证会，在下面都有无数的会议、会前会议和战略会议。这就是我来此要观察的工作。
This really doesn't-- the real reason--
这真的不……真正的原因……
Nadler and his staff are gathered in his newly giant office, strategizing around their first oversight hearing. He's editing a letter half out loud. His typical pose, bottom drawer of his desk pulled out, his right foot up on it, and leaning way too far back, like he's going to tip over. He's making notes, debating with his staff.
纳德勒和他的职员聚集在他那新扩建的超大办公室里，为他们的第一次监督听证会制定战略。他正半出声地修改一封信。他典型的姿势是，拉开办公桌底部的抽屉，右脚踩在上面，身体向后靠得太多，好像要翻倒一样。他正在做笔记，与职员们辩论。
Well, I don't know that they're bound by it. Right.
嗯，我不知道他们是否受此约束。对。
Nadler's like their constitutional law professor. He is actually a constitutional lawyer. Nadler's 71 years old, a liberal congressman from New York, represents primarily the West Side of Manhattan, spends a lot of weekends with a megaphone hollering about civil rights, spends his weekdays with piles of paper.
纳德勒就像他们的宪法学教授。他实际上确实是一位宪法律师。纳德勒71岁，来自纽约的自由派国会议员，主要代表曼哈顿西区，周末经常拿着扩音器高喊关于民权的话题，平日则处理堆积如山的文件。
Where's the stuff about Mueller?
关于穆勒的东西在哪儿？
This is back in January. Nadler and his staff want acting Attorney General Matthew Whitaker to appear before the Judiciary Committee. This letter is negotiating a time and sending him topic areas they want to cover-- the southern border, the Affordable Care Act, and primarily questions about you, sir, and your highly unusual, brief tenure as attorney general.
这是在一月份。纳德勒和他的职员希望代理司法部长马修·惠特克出现在司法委员会面前。这封信是在协商时间，并列出他们想要涵盖的主题——南部边境、平价医疗法案，以及主要是关于您，先生，还有您作为司法部长那极不寻常且短暂的任期的问题。
Whitaker is important, even though he's a temporary villain. He's a plot point in the story Nadler and the House Democrats want to tell. Or he might be. That's why they need to ask him a bunch of questions in a hearing under oath.
惠特克很重要，尽管他是个临时反派。他是纳德勒和民主党人想要讲述的故事中的一个情节要点。或者可能是。这就是为什么他们需要在宣誓听证会上问他一堆问题。
We all suspect he was put there for one reason and one reason only, to interfere with the Mueller investigation. Sessions--
我们都怀疑他被放在那里只有一个原因，而且是唯一的原因，那就是干扰穆勒调查。塞申斯……
Former Attorney General Jeff Sessions, Whitaker replaced him.
前司法部长杰夫·塞申斯，惠特克接替了他。
Sessions recused himself and wouldn't protect the president against the Mueller investigation. Is fired because he wouldn't protect the president against the Mueller investigation. Whitaker, who's written nasty things about the Mueller investigation, is hired with no visible qualifications. [INAUDIBLE] obviously for the purpose of protecting the president from the Mueller investigation.
塞申斯回避了，不会保护总统免受穆勒调查。因为他不保护总统免受穆勒调查而被解雇。惠特克，他写过关于穆勒调查的恶毒言论，在没有任何明显资格的情况下被聘用。（听不清）显然是为了保护总统免受穆勒调查。
Whatever is obvious to Nadler, if he wants the public to believe it, he's got to show it in a hearing. His committee needs to ask pointed questions and make sure Whitaker answers them. That's the letter full of topics that Nadler's working on.
无论这对纳德勒来说多么明显，如果他想让公众相信，他必须在听证会上表现出来。他的委员会需要问尖锐的问题，并确保惠特克回答。这就是纳德勒正在处理的那封写满主题的信。
At this point, he may not answer the questions. And we can't tolerate that.
在这一点上，他可能不会回答问题。我们不能容忍这一点。
That is correct.
那是正确的。
OK, that's what I'll say.
好吧，我就会这么说。
That voice in the background is Aaron, Nadler's deputy chief counsel. Aaron's one of the two people on Nadler's core staff who's allowed, sometimes, to speak into a microphone. He believes really hard in his job. Instead of saying the country, he'll say the republic.
背景中那个声音是亚伦，纳德勒的副首席律师。亚伦是纳德勒核心员工中偶尔被允许对着麦克风说话的两人之一。他非常坚定地相信自己的工作。他不常说“国家”，而是说“共和国”。
Now one question we should discuss is whether we should prepare a subpoena for Whitaker, even though we hopefully would never have to use it.
现在我们应该讨论的一个问题是，我们是否应该为惠特克准备一张传票，尽管我们希望永远不必使用它。
We should certainly prepare it. My only question is, does that look belligerent, like we're doing something?
我们当然应该准备好。我唯一的问题是，这看起来是不是很咄咄逼人，好像我们是在做秀？
That's the concern.
那是令人担忧的。
Nadler and his staff are considering deploying the biggest weapon they have early in the game, the subpoena. You'll hear a lot about the subpoena in this story and, I believe, in the coming months. A subpoena forces you to show up to a congressional hearing. A subpoena can also force you to answer questions, unless you plead the fifth, obviously.
纳德勒和他的职员正在考虑在博弈早期就部署他们拥有的最大武器——传票。在这个故事中，你将听到很多关于传票的内容，我相信，在未来几个月也是如此。传票强制你出席国会听证会。传票还可以强制你回答问题，除非你援引第五修正案，显然。
Back when the Democrats were in the minority, they didn't have the power to subpoena anybody. It killed them the last two years, not being able to force Trump officials to come in and answer for the stuff they were doing. Now they have subpoena power. And they have two years of unanswered questions.
当民主党在少数党时，他们没有传唤任何人的权力。过去两年没能强迫特朗普官员前来为他们的所作所为负责，这让他们抓狂。现在他们有了传票权。他们还有两年未得到解答的问题。
We have to reestablish proper oversight, not because we don't like this president-- though, I don't-- not because I think he's a terrible president-- though, I do-- not because I think we'll find all kinds of things-- though, we may-- but because it is our job to do that.
我们必须重建适当的监督，不是因为我们不喜欢这位总统——尽管我确实不喜欢——不是因为我认为他是个糟糕的总统——尽管我确实认为他是——不是因为我认为我们会发现各种各样的事情——尽管我们可能发现——而是因为做这件事是我们的职责。
Whitaker is coming in voluntarily. Nadler doesn't need the subpoena for that anymore, but he does want to use it to combat this maddening thing that's been going on over the last two years the Democrats were powerless to stop. People from the Trump administration would come in and refuse to answer questions. And every administration does that, but there's been a twist on it.
惠特克是自愿来的。纳德勒不再需要传票来实现这一点，但他确实想用它来打击过去两年民主党无力阻止的那种令人抓狂的行为。来自特朗普政府的人会来这里并拒绝回答问题。每一届政府都这样做，但这里面有个转折。
We saw it, for example, with the guy Whitaker replaced, Attorney General Sessions. A year ago, he went before a congressional committee and showcased this innovative way of not answering a question. Here's Sessions. This is from a New York Times video montage.
我们看到了，例如，惠特克接替的那个人，司法部长塞申斯。一年前，他在国会委员会面前展示了这种不回答问题的创新方式。这是塞申斯。这是来自《纽约时报》的视频剪辑。
Senator Heinrich, I'm not able to share with this committee private communications I may have--
海因里希参议员，我无法与本委员会分享我可能有的私人通讯……
Because you're invoking executive privilege.
因为你正在援引行政特权。
I'm not able to invoke executive privilege. That's the president's prerogative.
我无法援引行政特权。那是总统的特权。
Has the president invoked executive privilege in the case of your testimony here today?
总统是否在您今天作证的案件中援引了行政特权？
He has not.
他没有。
Then what is the basis of your refusal to answer these questions?
那么你拒绝回答这些问题的依据是什么？
I am protecting the right of the president to assert it if he chooses.
我正在保护总统选择援引该特权的权利。
Sessions drove the Democrats crazy because he kept talking in terms of future executive privilege. The president might invoke it sometime, hypothetically, potentially, and I have to protect that. He kept claiming this even after he was given months to go to the president and ask, over which communications do you want to invoke executive privilege?
塞申斯让民主党人抓狂，因为他一直用“未来行政特权”来搪塞。总统可能会在某个时候援引它，假设的，潜在的，我必须保护这一点。即使在给了他几个月的时间去问总统“你想对哪些通讯援引行政特权”之后，他仍然坚持这种说法。
This potential executive privilege was like a back door Sessions kept slipping out of. Nadler spent the last few months trying to nail that door shut. He sent a list of questions to Whitaker in advance. Are these subject to executive privilege? Go to the president, find that out, get back to us. Anything the president doesn't claim is fair game for us to ask and get answers to. And if you don't answer those questions, we'll subpoena the answers out of you.
这种潜在的行政特权就像塞申斯一直溜走的一扇后门。纳德勒过去几个月一直在试图把那扇门钉死。他预先向惠特克发送了一份问题清单。这些是否受行政特权约束？去问总统，查清楚，回来告诉我们。总统没有声明的任何内容都是我们可以问并得到答案的公平游戏。如果你不回答这些问题，我们将通过传票强制你回答。
Weeks passed. Whitaker didn't get back to Nadler, who feels like, OK, if you try to stonewall, we'll subpoena your answers mid-hearing. But to get a subpoena for a hearing, first, Nadler is having a hearing about a subpoena. This is Congress, after all.
几周过去了。惠特克没有回复纳德勒，纳德勒觉得，好吧，如果你想推诿，我们会在听证会中途传唤你的答案。但要获得听证会传票，首先，纳德勒要举行关于传票的听证会。毕竟，这是国会。
The Judiciary Committee will please come to order, a quorum being present without objection. The chair has authorized to declare a recess at any time.
请司法委员会开会，法定人数已到，无异议。主席已授权在任何时候宣布休会。
Nadler is sitting in the chairman's seat with the gavel, opening a meeting about the subpoena. It's the day before the big Whittaker hearing. This meeting is focused on just the subpoena. It's called a markup, basically a debate among the committee members. And it's teeny, tiny-- no audience, very few reporters. Not even all the committee members are here. I called C-Span and asked if they were recording it. They were like, what is that?
纳德勒坐在主席的位子上，拿着木槌，开始讨论关于传票的会议。这是惠特克听证会的前一天。这次会议只集中在传票上。这被称为“标记”，基本上是委员会成员之间的辩论。而且规模很小——没有观众，很少有记者。甚至不是所有的委员会成员都到场了。我打电话给C-SPAN问他们是否在录音。他们反应是，那是什么？
I now call up the chair's resolution, authorizing the issuance of a subpoena to acting Attorney General Matthew G. Whitaker to secure his appearance and testimony at the hearing of the committee regarding oversight of the US Department of Justice. I move that the committee adopt the resolution.
我现在提请主席的决议，授权向代理司法部长马修·G·惠特克发出传票，以确保他出席并就委员会关于监督美国司法部的听证会作证。我动议委员会通过该决议。
So this hearing is about the subpoena, but it's also a way for Democrats to show off how transparent they're going to be as they run this committee. Back when Nadler was in the minority, it frustrated him that the Democrats wouldn't get a chance to weigh in on a subpoena like this. There weren't committee votes, markups where Democrats got to go on the record and vote no when they didn't like what the Republicans were doing.
所以这次听证会是关于传票的，但这也是民主党人展示他们运行这个委员会将有多透明的一种方式。当纳德勒还在少数党时，民主党人没有机会对这样的传票发表意见，这让他感到沮丧。没有委员会投票，没有让民主党人能够记录在案并在不喜欢共和党所作所为时投下反对票的标记程序。
Today, Nadler and the Democrats could just go ahead and authorize a subpoena without this hearing, but they're letting the Republicans weigh in. And they're feeling a little holier than thou about it. Also, Nadler genuinely believes in proper parliamentary procedure, not just the technicalities of it, but the idea of it, that it's a way to keep everyone honest. The chairman begins by recognizing himself for an opening statement, because that's the procedure. Not a showboat. Whatever's under-understated is how Nadler presents himself.
今天，纳德勒和民主党人本来可以直接在没有这次听证会的情况下授权传票，但他们正在让共和党人发表意见。他们对此感到有点自命不凡。而且，纳德勒真诚地相信适当的议会程序，不仅仅是技术细节，而是它的理念，即这是一种保持每个人诚实的方式。主席首先为开场白认领了时间，因为这是程序。不是在作秀。无论什么，纳德勒表现得都很低调。
My staff and I can not have been more transparent about our goals here. We explained the possibility of this subpoena to Mr. Whitaker months ago. We provided him with the questions in advance weeks ago. We consulted with ranking member Collins and provided him with a copy of this subpoena days ago so that we could schedule this markup if necessary. In fact, we are only voting on this resolution because the ranking member asked us for an up or down vote on the matter, a courtesy we were not afforded in the last Congress when Democrats were in the minority.
我和我的职员对我们在这里的目标已然非常透明。我们几个月前就向惠特克先生解释了这张传票的可能性。我们几周前就提前提供了问题。我们咨询了排名成员柯林斯，并于几天前向他提供了传票副本，以便我们在必要时安排这次标记。事实上，我们投票通过这项决议只是因为排名成员要求我们对此事进行赞成或反对投票，这是上一届国会民主党在少数党时没有享受到的礼遇。
The hearing is filled with digs like that, back and forth. Well, back when you guys didn't follow the rules, back when your president was the one being secretive. This is the way it's going to be for two years. And these are the people who are going to be doing it. This is the cast for the new season. Let's get to know them.
听证会上充满了这样的挖苦，反复来回。嗯，回到你们这些家伙不遵守规则的时候，回到你们的总统才是那个保密的人的时候。这就是未来两年的状况。这些人就是将要这么做的人。这是新赛季的演员阵容。让我们来认识他们。
Ranking Republican Doug Collins from Georgia, charismatic talker, Air Force Reserve, Iraq vet. He steers things away from Whitaker immediately and does a classic, what about Obama and his attorney general, Eric Holder? And isn't your subpoena here a double standard?
排名共和党人道格·柯林斯，来自佐治亚州，极具魅力的演说家，空军预备役，伊拉克老兵。他立即将话题从惠特克身上引开，并做了一个经典的：奥巴马和他的司法部长埃里克·霍尔德呢？你们的传票难道不是双重标准吗？
A subpoena should not be used to supplement where the committee is merely worried that a witness might not testify or might not answer questions to the extent of the committee's liking. If that was the standard for a subpoena, many on our side, especially when Attorney General Holder sat at that table and offered, on the record, the executive privilege, which he could not claim. Let's be honest about this.
传票不应被用来补充委员会仅仅担心证人可能不会作证或可能不会以委员会喜欢的程度回答问题的情况。如果这是传票的标准，我们这边很多人，尤其是当霍尔德司法部长坐在那张桌子上并记录在案提供行政特权时，他无法主张。让我们诚实地对待这一点。
There's arguing back and forth about whether waving a subpoena around is too rude for someone coming in voluntarily, and what's the precedent. Here's Nadler sparring with Jim Jordan, Republican from Ohio, who loves a fight. Big defender of the president.
关于挥舞传票对一个自愿前来的人是否太粗鲁，以及先例是什么，存在着争论。这里是纳德勒与吉姆·乔丹（俄亥俄州共和党人）的交锋，他喜欢战斗。他是总统的坚定捍卫者。
The issue is, if he refuses to answer legitimate questions. That is why we want the subpoena.
问题是，如果他拒绝回答合法的问题。这就是为什么我们需要传票。
How do you know that until he comes tomorrow? And he said he's coming.
你怎么知道在他明天来之前会那样？而且他说他会来。
Sir, I'm speaking. We don't know that. He hasn't told us what he will do. We asked him. He refuses to say--
先生，我在发言。我们不知道。他没有告诉我们他会做什么。我们问过他。他拒绝说……
Mr. Chairman, that's actually not accurate. He has told you what he's going to do. He said he's going to be sitting at that table tomorrow morning at 10 o'clock.
主席先生，这其实是不准确的。他已经告诉你他打算做什么了。他说他明天早上10点会坐在那张桌子旁。
No, he hasn't told us about answering questions.
不，他没告诉我们要回答问题。
Finally, after arguing against the subpoena for a while, the Republicans changed tack and offered an amendment to it.
最后，在反对传票一段时间后，共和党人改变了策略，并提出了一项修正案。
Thank you, Mr. Chairman. I have an amendment at the desk.
谢谢，主席先生。桌子上有一项修正案。
You have an amendment at the desk?
你桌上有一项修正案？
The clerk reads the amendment.
书记员宣读修正案。
Beginning on page one, after "acting Attorney General Matthew G. Whitaker," and before "to secure his appearance," insert the following-- "and Deputy Attorney General Rod Rosenstein."
第一页，在“代理司法部长马修·G·惠特克”之后，“以确保他出席”之前，插入以下内容——“以及副司法部长罗德·罗森斯坦”。
Here we go. If you're getting a subpoena anyway, get one for Rod Rosenstein. Rod Rosenstein, deputy attorney general. Lots of Republicans can't stand him and think he's out to get the president. So their amendment is basically, you Democrats want the guy you don't trust at the Justice Department to testify. Well, then we want the guy we don't trust to come in at the same time.
我们来了。如果你反正要弄一张传票，那就给罗德·罗森斯坦也弄一张吧。罗德·罗森斯坦，副司法部长。很多共和党人恨死他了，认为他要对付总统。所以他们的修正案基本上是：你们民主党人想要你们不信任的司法部的人作证，好，那我们想要我们不信任的人同时进来。
The argument that follows is so small sized, but they all throw in so hard, which is normal here. Just stay with it for a second. The Democrats' response is led by David Cicilline from Rhode Island. I've come to think of him as Nadler's pinch hitter.
随后的争论规模很小，但他们都非常投入，这在这里很正常。请稍等片刻。民主党人的回应由来自罗得岛州的大卫·西西里尼领导。我开始认为他是纳德勒的代打。
Thank you, Mr. Chairman. I would argue that this amendment goes beyond the scope of the resolution before us.
谢谢，主席先生。我认为这项修正案超出了我们面前决议的范围。
The Democrats knew this amendment was coming. Nadler's team already set up Cicilline with what he needs to knock it down.
民主党人知道这项修正案要来了。纳德勒的团队已经为西西里尼设置好了击败它所需的东西。
His addition to this resolution is not germane. It expands the scope of this for the individual charged with the oversight of the Department of Justice. And therefore, I ask that you rule it out of order.
他加入这个决议是不相关的。它扩大了对负责司法部监督的个人的范围。因此，我要求你裁定它不符合议事规则。
"Germane" is a legal term. And once it's released in here, it's like a swarm of bees. Republican member Biggs argues back.
“相关”是一个法律术语。一旦在这里发布，就像一群蜜蜂。共和党议员比格斯反驳道。
Because under the rules of any parliamentary body, this group determines what's germane. This group determines what's germane. We're going to vote on germane, this in just a second.
因为根据任何议会机构的规则，这个团体决定什么是相关的。这个团体决定什么是相关的。我们马上就要对“相关”进行投票。
Another Republican, Louie Gohmert from East Texas, he jumps in. Like not only is Rod Rosenstein germane--
另一位共和党人，来自德克萨斯州东部的路易·戈默特，插嘴说。不仅罗德·罗森斯坦是相关的……
It is extremely germane.
这是极其相关的。
--can't be germaner.
……不能更相关了。
It's as germane as it gets. So let's be fair.
它是再相关不过了。所以让我们公平一点。
In any event, the Democrats have the votes to do what they want. Nadler rules the amendment not germane. The Republicans appeal. Democrats immediately table the appeal-- swat it down, in other words. They finally vote on the resolution to authorize the actual subpoena. And it is authorized, obviously, by a party line vote of Democrats.
无论如何，民主党人有足够的选票做他们想做的事。纳德勒裁定该修正案不相关。共和党人上诉。民主党人立即搁置了上诉——换句话说，把它拍下去。他们最终投票决定授权实际的传票。显然，这是由民主党人按党派投票授权的。
This entire show, the whole hour of debate, it was a fait accompli from the beginning. But the minority got what the minority gets, a chance to object on the record. It ain't much, but it's all there is. Everyone knows that. And yet, at the very end of the hearing, Republican Louie Gohmert, knowing the Democrats are feeling so very pleased with themselves for letting the minority speak, Gohmert gets in one last graciously worded dig at the majority. He's like, you played your part a little sloppy. You didn't even make it look like you were listening to us.
整个节目，整整一个小时的辩论，从一开始就是既成事实。但少数党得到了少数党应得的，一个记录在案反对的机会。虽然不多，但这就是全部了。大家都知道这一点。然而，在听证会快结束时，共和党人路易·戈默特，知道民主党人因为让少数党发言而对自己感觉非常良好，戈默特对多数党进行了最后一次优雅的挖苦。他说，你们扮演自己的角色有点马虎。你们甚至没有假装在听我们说话。
I rise to commend the chairman on the way in which he ruled on the germaneness issue of-- we know that to rule before giving this side a chance to respond on a germaneness objection would be a sign of partisan railroading. And whoever it is that typed up your answer and had it instantaneously at the very moment we finished our argument in front of you so you could read it so fast we couldn't even see it-- they typed it, got it to you so you could read your ruling the moment we finished stating our position.
我起身称赞主席在处理相关性问题上的裁决——我们知道在没有给予这一方机会回应相关性异议之前就做出裁决，将是党派横行霸道的标志。而不管是哪个人敲出了你的答案，并在我们结束辩论那一刻立即放在你面前，让你读得这么快，我们甚至没看清——他们敲好了，交给你，让你在我们陈述立场结束的那一刻读出你的裁决。
Will the gentleman--
那位先生愿意……
I commend the--
我称赞……
I thank the gentleman.
我感谢那位先生。
Everyone laughed. They went on to consider a bipartisan bill, which they passed out of committee. The Democrats felt great about how this markup went. They authorized a subpoena, meaning now they had the power to use a subpoena on the day of the hearing to compel answers, if they want to, just to have it on hand, like in case of emergency, break glass, get answers.
大家都笑了。他们继续审议一项两党法案，并将其从委员会通过。民主党人对这次标记会议的进展感觉非常好。他们授权了一张传票，意味着现在他们有权在听证会当天使用传票来强制回答，如果他们愿意的话，只是为了备用，就像“紧急情况，打破玻璃，获取答案”一样。
We get backstage, as it were, back to the vast suite of the majority's offices behind the hearing room. And I find Aaron, who's full of his particular brand of patriotic bonhomie.
我们来到后台，正如人们所说，回到听证室后面多数党庞大的办公室套房。我找到了亚伦，他充满了那种爱国主义的友善。
So who do you think won?
所以你觉得谁赢了？
The American people, I'd say.
美国人民，我会说。
No. [LAUGHING]
不。（笑声）
Many members had sort of a moment where they pulled me aside and said, oh, we're going to win a vote today, because it's been a while. It's our first game time, like regular season, vote.
许多议员都有过一个时刻，他们把我拉到一边说，哦，我们今天会赢得一场投票，因为这已经有一段时间了。这是我们的第一场比赛时间，就像常规赛投票一样。
As the day ends and we head into Whitaker oversight hearing eve, everything seems set. Nadler staff is feeling ready, like they had a great dress rehearsal and the play is also going to be great. The props are all in place. Everyone knows their lines. Every box has been checked off.
随着这一天结束，我们进入惠特克监督听证会的前夜，一切似乎都准备好了。纳德勒的职员感觉准备就绪，就像他们进行了一次伟大的彩排，演出也会很棒。道具都在位了。每个人都知道自己的台词。每一个方框都勾选了。
I go downstairs to the Rayburn Cafeteria, stare at my phone, like everyone does. Suddenly news breaks, and it's big. I look up from my phone to CNN, which is playing everywhere. The Whitaker hearing that is supposed to happen in just hours, the hearing the Democrats have been rehearsing for, planning for, might not happen now.
我下楼到雷伯恩自助餐厅，盯着我的手机，像所有人一样。突然新闻爆发了，而且是大事。我从手机抬头看向到处都在播放的CNN。原本应该在几个小时内举行的惠特克听证会，民主党人一直在排练、计划的听证会，现在可能不会发生了。
Whitaker apparently heard about the vote they just took on the subpoena. And now he's saying he's not going to come tomorrow if there's a subpoena threat. In other words, this new tool the Democrats can wield, now that they're in the majority, the main tool they want to use to get the answers they've been waiting for, the DOJ is saying, go ahead and try it. See what you get.
惠特克显然听说了他们刚刚对传票进行的投票。现在他说如果传票威胁存在，他明天就不会来了。换句话说，民主党人在多数党时可以挥舞的这个新工具，他们想要用来得到他们一直等待的答案的主要工具，司法部在说，去试试看。看看你能得到什么。
If Whitaker doesn't show up like he's threatening, a subpoena can force him to appear, but it would take a while. I run back upstairs. People are gathered around the TV in the office, watching the breaking news.
如果惠特克像他威胁的那样不出现，传票可以强迫他出席，但这需要一段时间。我跑回楼上。人们聚集在办公室的电视机前，观看突发新闻。
Acting attorney general to discuss his communications with the president. So that's a [INAUDIBLE]---
代理司法部长讨论他与总统的通讯。所以那是一个……
Oh, my god.
天哪。
[INAUDIBLE]
……
Nadler's staff is in Aaron's office with the door closed. They're all on speakerphone with Nadler. And I sit outside watching MSNBC for what feels like hours, but I think is like 45 minutes.
纳德勒的职员在亚伦的办公室里，门关着。他们都在和纳德勒通话。我坐在外面看MSNBC，感觉就像过了几个小时，但我想大约是45分钟。
Finally, they come get me. And Aaron and another staffer, Danny, show me what they've all been looking at. It's a five-page letter they just now received from the DOJ, telling them Whitaker won't come if there's a chance the Democrats will use their subpoena at the hearing tomorrow. To be clear, it's a PDF, but it sounds like it's from the 19th century.
最后，他们来接我了。亚伦和另一位职员丹尼向我展示了他们一直在看的东西。这是一封他们刚刚收到的司法部发来的五页信件，告诉他们如果明天听证会上民主党人有机会使用传票，惠特克就不会来。说清楚，这是PDF，但听起来像是19世纪的东西。
So the department says, "Given the concerns expressed above, we seek a written assurance from your office that the committee will not issue a subpoena to the acting attorney general on or before February 8." Oh, "We request the benefit of your reply by 6:00 PM today." So the threshold question is--
所以部门说，“鉴于上述表达的担忧，我们寻求你们办公室的书面保证，即委员会不会在2月8日或之前向代理司法部长发出传票。”哦，“我们请求在今天下午6点之前得到回复。”所以门槛问题是……
So formal.
太正式了。
Yeah. The threshold question is, do we respond to this at all? This is a last minute threat. It's out of the box. It's irregular.
是的。门槛问题是，我们是否要对此做出回应？这是一个最后一分钟的威胁。这不符合常规。这是不规则的。
Attempting to dictate terms from the executive branch to the legislative branch on how to conduct its oversight of the executive branch.
试图从行政部门向下到立法部门发布指令，关于如何进行对行政部门的监督。
They're indignant and a little shaken, I'd say. They're like, wait, did we mess this up? Is Whitaker seriously not coming? What do we do now?
他们感到愤慨，有点动摇，我会说。他们像是，等等，是我们搞砸了吗？惠特克真的不来了吗？我们现在该怎么办？
F this guy.
去他的。
They're legitimately freaked out because they really, really want Whitaker to come in. Nadler's the new leader. All his members might be upset. They stuck their necks out and supported his subpoena move, but they really want to have a hearing with the cabinet official, to be the first committee in the new Democrat-controlled House to show off a tough oversight agenda.
他们确实被吓坏了，因为他们非常、非常想让惠特克来。纳德勒是新领导。他所有的成员可能都很不高兴。他们伸长脖子支持他的传票举动，但他们真的想和内阁官员举行听证会，成为新民主党控制的众议院中第一个展示强硬监督议程的委员会。
Aaron and Danny walk me through their various options for a response, from hard line to pushover. People are running around, researching ways to beef up their response to the letter. Nadler's decision is, just reiterate what they said before as though it's not exactly what they said before. Basically, as Aaron puts it--
亚伦和丹尼带我了解了他们回应的各种方案，从强硬路线到软弱。人们到处跑，研究加强回复信件的方法。纳德勒的决定是，重申他们之前说的话，就好像这不完全是他们之前说的话一样。基本上，正如亚伦所说的——
Dear Matthew Whitaker, if you show up on time prepared to answer our questions, there is no need for us to issue a subpoena. Love, Jerry Nadler.
亲爱的马修·惠特克，如果你准时出现并准备回答我们的问题，我们就不需要发出传票。爱你的，杰里·纳德勒。
So then Aaron and another staffer call the DOJ. I'm not allowed to record. They start out by saying, I've got good news for you. And the news is not good. They say, well, the gist is, if he shows up on time and answers questions, we won't have to issue a subpoena.
所以亚伦和另一位职员给司法部打电话。我不被允许录音。他们开始说，我有个好消息要告诉你。消息并不好。他们说，嗯，要点是，如果他准时出现并回答问题，我们就不用发出传票了。
It seems to somehow pass muster with whoever's on the other side. And they talk about logistics, what elevator Whitaker is going to use, how he's going to get into the hearing room and stuff. The way they talk is like they're releasing a bull into a ring, how to keep everyone safe before we let this angry, frightened creature in front of 30 matadors.
这似乎不知何故通过了对方的审查。他们谈论后勤，惠特克将使用哪部电梯，他将如何进入听证室等等。他们谈话的方式就像是在向斗牛场释放一头公牛，在我们将这个愤怒、受惊的生物放到30名斗牛士面前之前，如何保证每个人的安全。
Things are calm for about a half an hour. Then Aaron's cell phone rings on his watch, and he curses and runs out of the room. It's the DOJ. They want a stronger assurance. They want a promise-- no subpoena tomorrow, or Whitaker won't come.
事情平静了大约半个小时。然后亚伦手表的手机响了，他咒骂着跑出了房间。是司法部。他们想要更强的保证。他们想要一个承诺——明天没有传票，否则惠特克就不会来。
It's 10 to 6:00. 6:00 is the deadline. This time, the team gathers deeper into their catacombs of offices. I can't even hear them arguing, they're so cocooned away from me. And when they come out, I can't get a straight answer out of Danny or Aaron.
6点差10分。6点是截止日期。这一次，团队聚集在他们办公室更深处的地下墓穴中。我甚至听不到他们争论，他们太与我隔绝了。当他们出来时，我无法从丹尼或亚伦那里得到明确的答案。
He asked for a guarantee. You didn't give him a guarantee, or did you?
他要求保证。你没有给他保证，还是你给了？
We said that there's no need for a subpoena.
我们说不需要传票。
But did you guarantee him that you wouldn't issue a subpoena?
但你保证他你不会发出传票了吗？
Yeah. There's no need to issue a subpoena because he's agreed to come in tomorrow morning and answer the questions.
是的。不需要发出传票，因为他已经同意明天早上来回答问题。
OK. So what if he doesn't answer one of the questions, and you want him to answer it?
好吧。那如果他不回答其中一个问题，而你想要他回答呢？
We'll deal with it as we move forward.
我们会在前进的过程中处理它。
But isn't that when you would issue a subpoena?
但那不是你会发出传票的时候吗？
If, in fact, we were going to issue a subpoena.
如果，事实上，我们要发出传票的话。
Oh, my god.
天哪。
They're being so cagey, so parsey, I can't quite tell what's up. Did they cave, and they don't want to admit it? Later that night, the ranking Republican on the Judiciary Committee, Doug Collins, gets on Twitter to reveal Nadler caved. Nadler's team protests that word, "caved," vehemently.
他们太谨慎了，太含糊了，我无法分辨到底发生了什么。他们投降了，但不想承认吗？那天晚上晚些时候，司法委员会的排名共和党人道格·柯林斯在推特上揭露了纳德勒投降了。纳德勒的团队激烈地抗议“投降”这个词。
The way they put it is, they decided getting Whitaker in the room was the most important thing. "Caved" is definitely the word Collins would use. And he posted a screenshot of a letter from Nadler to the DOJ, a letter that Nadler's team hadn't made public, a letter they also hadn't told me about. It promises the DOJ no subpoena tomorrow. Collins is all, got you, Nadler. "Looks like @repjerrynadler forgot to include his most recent letter to acting AG Whitaker, confirming there would be no subpoena tomorrow. Here it is."
他们的说法是，他们决定让惠特克进入房间是最重要的事情。“投降”绝对是柯林斯会用的词。他发布了一封从纳德勒发给司法部的信的截图，一封纳德勒团队没有公开的信，一封他们也没有告诉我的信。它承诺司法部明天没有传票。柯林斯是，“抓到你了，纳德勒。”“看起来@repjerrynadler忘了包括他最近给代理司法部长惠特克的信，确认明天没有传票。这是它。”
Collins, as ranking Republican on the Judiciary Committee, should have been CC'd on this letter. Nadler's team says they did. Collins says they did not. He got it elsewhere. So much for proper procedure.
作为司法委员会的排名共和党人，柯林斯应该收到这封信的抄送。纳德勒的团队说他们抄送了。柯林斯说他们没有。他是从别处得到的。适当的程序到此为止。
Congressional hearings can be confusing because there's so many different things at once. They can be investigations to find out facts you didn't know. They can trap people into making false statements on the record, also cable TV performances to raise representatives' national profile or send a message to their constituents.
国会听证会可能会令人困惑，因为同时有太多不同的事情。它们可以是找出你不知道的事实的调查。它们可以诱捕人们在记录上做出虚假陈述，也可以是为提升代表的全国形象或向选民传达信息而进行的有线电视表演。
This hearing is going to be all those things. But also, the Democrats want to show the public what they think is going on, which in terms of Whitaker is, they think he's a hatchet man, that he was put in place to kill or screw up the Mueller investigation. Nadler believes that's why Trump picked him. And picking Whitaker was just one of any number of times he believes the president may have obstructed justice.
这次听证会将是所有这些事情。而且，民主党人想向公众展示他们认为正在发生的事情，就惠特克而言，他们认为他是刽子手，他被安排来杀死或搞砸穆勒调查。纳德勒相信这就是特朗普选择他的原因。挑选惠特克只是他认为总统可能妨碍司法公正的无数次中的一次。
We have to lay out a story for the American people. We have to find out what was going on and then lay that out to the American people. And that's our job.
我们必须为美国人民梳理一个故事。我们必须查明发生了什么，然后向美国人民梳理出来。这就是我们的工作。
Also, separate from Whitaker's appointment, they're really mad about a whole bunch of Trump, DOJ-related matters. And they want to get answers about those too. So it's going to be a long day. Right before it starts, Aaron and Nadler review his script and his questions.
此外，与惠特克的任命分开，他们对一系列特朗普、司法部相关的事情感到非常愤怒。他们也想得到关于那些事情的答案。所以这将是漫长的一天。就在它开始之前，亚伦和纳德勒回顾了他的剧本和他的问题。
And the central question that we should talk about right now is not actually the questions, but what happens when we're in the moment where he refuses to answer.
我们需要谈论现在的核心问题实际上不是问题，而是当他拒绝回答时我们该怎么办。
All right. [INAUDIBLE]
好吧。（听不清）
OK, let's talk through it.
好吧，让我们谈谈它。
I like the way you set up yes or no, Mr. Whitaker?
我喜欢你设置“是或否，惠特克先生？”的方式。
Yes or no, Mr. Whitaker? Hit him again and again with that.
是或否，惠特克先生？一遍又一遍地用那个打他。
About an hour later, the hearing's getting underway. We're in the room with the portraits looking down from the walls. Whitaker shows up right on time. Ranking Republican member Doug Collins speaks directly to him in his opening statement.
大约一个小时后，听证会正在进行中。我们坐在墙上挂着画像的房间里。惠特克准时出现了。排名共和党成员道格·柯林斯在他的开场白中直接对他说话。
Mr. Whitaker, this is your life. Like the old TV show, they just want a piece of you. And with that, Mr. Chairman, pursuant calls for Rule 16. I do now move to adjourn.
惠特克先生，这就是你的一生。像旧电视节目一样，他们只是想要你的一块。鉴于此，主席先生，依据规则16的呼吁。我现在动议休会。
Nobody asked me, but I think we shouldn't be having this hearing.
没人问我，但我认为我们不应该举行这次听证会。
All in favor of the motion to adjourn, say aye.
所有赞成休会动议的人，请说赞成。
Aye.
赞成。
Oppose, nay.
反对，反对。
No.
不。
The no's have it.
反对票占多数。
Collins calls for a roll call vote.
柯林斯要求点名投票。
Roll call.
点名。
Everyone's vote on adjournment is painstakingly read out loud. That's four minutes less hearing, classic minority party stalling tactic. Also literally, Collins doesn't think we should be having this hearing. Whitaker opening statement, Nadler moves to questions. Right off the bat, Nadler's tactic of yes or no, Mr. Whitaker, gets mixed results.
每个人对休会的投票都被吃力地大声读出来。那比听证会少了四分钟，这是少数党拖延战术的经典。而且字面上说，柯林斯不认为我们应该举行这次听证会。惠特克开场白，纳德勒进入提问。一开始，纳德勒“是或否，惠特克先生”的战术结果好坏参半。
Well, it's our understanding that at least one briefing occurred in December before your decision not to recuse yourself on December 19 and Christmas Day. Is that correct?
嗯，我们的理解是，在12月19日和圣诞节那天你决定不回避之前，至少发生了一次简报。这是正确的吗？
What's the basis for that question, sir?
先生，那个问题的依据是什么？
Yes or no? Is it correct?
是或否？它是正确的吗？
I mean, I--
我的意思是，我……
It is our understanding that at least one briefing occurred between your decision not to recuse yourself on December 19 and six days later, Christmas Day. Is that correct? Simple enough question, yes or no?
我们的理解是，在你12月19日决定不回避之后到六天后的圣诞节之间，至少发生了一次简报。这是正确的吗？很简单的问题，是还是否？
Mr. Chairman, again, what is the basis for your question? You're saying that it is your--
主席先生，再次请问，你问题的依据是什么？你说这是你的……你告诉我依据在哪里？
Sir, I'm asking the questions. I only have five minutes, so please answer, yes or no.
不，我不会告诉你。我没时间去谈那个。我只是问你它是否正确。它是正确的吗？你在12月19日到圣诞节这段时间里得到了简报吗？简单的问题，是还是否？
No, Mr. Chairman. I'm going to-- you were asking me a question, it is your understanding-- can you tell me where you get the basis?
国会议员，如果今天在座的每位议员都基于他们的猜测提问……
No, I'm not going to tell you that. I'm don't have time to get into that. I'm just asking you if that's correct or not. Is it correct? Were you briefed in that time period between December 19 and Christmas Day? Simple question, yes or no?
好吧，没关系。在任何时候……
Congressman, if every member here today asked questions based on their mere speculation--
你没有实际的依据来问你的问题。
All right, never mind. At any point--
是还是否。
You don't have an an actual basis for your questions.
（争吵声）
Yes or no.
惠特克缓慢地完成每一个回答，花时间把小眼镜戴上和摘下，并定期拒绝回答。“国会议员，谢谢你的那个问题。国会议员，我知道这是一个对你很重要的议题。”即使当他回答时，答案也被包裹在奇怪、半非答案中。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
主席先生，正如我今天早些时候在开场白中所说，我今天不打算谈论我与美国总统的私人对话。但为了回答你的问题，我没有和美国总统谈论特别检察官的调查。
Whitaker plods slowly through every answer, taking time to pull his tiny glasses on and off his face and regularly declining to answer. Congressman, thank you for that question. Congressman, I know this is an important issue to you. And then even when he does answer, the answers are swaddled in weird, half non-answers.
所以答案是否定的，谢谢。那对任何其他白宫官员呢？
Mr. Chairman, as I said earlier today in my opening remarks, I do not intend today to talk about my private conversations with the President of the United States. But to answer your question, I have not talked to the President of the United States about the special counsel's investigation.
这导致的结果是，真的很难判断惠特克当司法部长时到底发生了什么，哪部分重要，而且重要的是，谁在无理取闹——是民主党人对他大喊“是或否”，还是惠特克太固执？他知道东西在隐瞒吗？他不知道东西，而他们在指责他？我真的无法分辨。
So the answer is no, thank you. To any other White House official?
听证会协议是民主党人五分钟，共和党人五分钟。每次他们切换时，都会有鞭打的感觉，因为他们试图用他们的问题讲述完全不同的故事。当排名共和党成员道格·柯林斯轮到提问时，他提出了罗杰·斯通最近被捕的事。
The effect of this is that it's really hard to tell what really went on while Whitaker was AG, which part matters, and importantly, who's being unreasonable-- Democrats for yelling yes or no at him, or Whittaker for being obstinate? Does he know stuff and he's hiding it? Does he not know stuff, and they're berating him? I truly cannot tell.
你是否从公共论坛或其他方面知道，当FBI逮捕斯通时，CNN记者就蹲守在斯通家外？
The hearing protocol is Democrat gets five minutes, Republican gets five minutes. And it's whiplash every time they switch because they're trying to tell entirely different stories with their questions. When it's ranking Republican Doug Collins' turn at bat, he brings up Roger Stone's recent arrest.
我意识到了这一点。至于CNN是如何发现的，我深感担忧。
Are you familiar, from public boards or otherwise, that a CNN reporter was camped out outside of Stone's house when the FBI arrested him?
嗯，我很高兴我们走上了那条路，司法部长先生，因为这是一个……
I am aware of that. And it was deeply concerning to me as to how CNN found out about that.
柯林斯用剩下的时间重申了他对FBI和司法部内部发生的怀疑。过去两年的共和党领导的听证会很多就是关于这个的。他们一直在推行一个故事，即FBI内部有偏见的官员一直试图在总统上任以来就把他搞掉。还有一个虚假的理论说斯通的被捕是其中的一部分。
Well, I'm glad we're going down that road, Mr. Attorney General, because this is a--
他们可能相信这一切。纳德勒说这是一种共和党抹黑这些调查的策略。所以当任何报告出来时，半个国家的人都不会相信它们。
Collins uses the rest of his time to reiterate his suspicions about goings on inside the FBI and Department of Justice. That's what a lot of the last two years of Republican-led hearings have been about. They've been pushing a story that biased officials inside the FBI have been trying to take down the president ever since he took office. And there's a bogus theory that says Stone's arrest is part of that.
惠特克非常擅长避开民主党人的问题，以至于我觉得我真正理解民主党人想要表达的意思的时候，只有当他们表演这些小独白时，背诵一系列已经存在的事实。罗得岛州的大卫·西西里尼，纳德勒的代打，利用他的一些时间给惠特克读了这样一个清单。
They may believe all this. Nadler says it's a Republican strategy to discredit these investigations. So when any reports do come out, half the country won't believe them.
然后你接着把穆勒任命特别检察官描述为荒谬和有点可疑，穆勒调查特朗普的财务状况是走得太远了，针对特朗普总统没有刑事妨碍司法罪，特朗普竞选活动与俄罗斯人没有勾结，任何候选人都会像小唐纳德·特朗普与俄罗斯律师那样采取同样的含义，最后是塞申斯的继任者可能会把穆勒的预算削减到如此之低以至于他的调查几乎陷入停滞。
Whitaker is so adept at deflecting the Democrats' questions that the only time I feel like I really understand what the Democrats are getting at is when they perform these little monologues, reciting a list of facts that are already out there. David Cicilline, Rhode Island, Nadler's pinch hitter, used some of his time to read a list like that to Whitaker.
你说了所有这些话，而且都有印刷记录。美国人民想知道惠特克先生是如何违反现行法规成为美国代理司法部长的。他被放在那里是为了特定的目的吗？那不是一个问题，这是一个陈述。我交回……
You then went on to describe the Mueller appointment of a special counsel as ridiculous and a little fishy, that Mueller investigating Trump's finances would be going too far, that there is no criminal obstruction of justice charge to be had against President Trump, that there was no collusion with the Russians in the Trump campaign, that any candidate would have taken the same meaning as Donald Trump Jr. with the Russian lawyer, and finally that a replacement for Sessions could reduce Mueller's budget so low that his investigation grinds to almost a halt.
我观察到了。那位先生的时间已经用完了。
You said all those things, and they're all in print. The American people wonder just how is it that Mr. Whitaker becomes the acting attorney general of the United States in violation of existing statutes. Was he put there for a particular purpose? That wasn't a question, it's a statement. I yield back--
这些演讲有助于理解为什么他们把惠特克带到这里。但当他们问问题时，它又变得混乱了。似乎他们试图到达一个地方，但也像是他们永远到不了那里。他们会进行一系列问题，是同一个问题的无休止的、微小的变化，最终没有结论。这里是民主党人泰德·多伊奇试图询问关于惠特克和白宫之间关于穆勒调查可能存在的每一种通讯方式。
I've observed that. The time of the gentleman has expired.
你有没有做任何事情来确保白宫可能了解到你在那些简报中了解到的一些东西？会不会是你的职员中的某个人可能和白宫里的某个人谈过，既然你告诉我们你没有？
The speeches are helpful in understanding why they brought Whitaker here. But when they ask questions, it gets muddled again. It seems as though there's a place they're trying to get to, but also like they might never get there. They'll do a series of questions that are endless, tiny variations on the same question that don't end in a conclusion. Here's Democrat Ted Deutch trying to ask about every single way there could've been communication between Whitaker and the White House about the Mueller investigation.
国会议员，我不知道发生了那种情况。
Did you do anything to make sure that the White House might have learned some of what you learned in those briefings? Could it be that someone else on your staff might have spoken to someone at the White House, since you told us you didn't?
还有谁……当你被告知穆勒调查时，有多少人和你一起参加了那些简报？
Congressman, I'm not aware of that happening.
国会议员，我不会深入简报的细节，但这只是一个非常有限的群体。只有我的一个职员在场。
Who else-- how many people were in those briefings with you when you're briefed about the Mueller investigation?
在与多伊奇议员的这段往来后不久，有一个休息时间。我冲到后台亚伦的办公室。他看到我很惊讶。
Congressman, I'm not going to go into specifics of the briefing, but it was a very limited group. There was only one member of my staff who was present with me.
嗨。
Shortly after this back and forth with Congressman Deutch, there was a break. I marched backstage to Aaron's office. He looked surprised to see me.
好的，你们在多伊奇一直纠缠的这个“你有没有告诉任何人”的事情上，有什么牌可以打吗？
Hi.
是的。我的意思是，与其说是打的牌，不如说我们有理由相信他的证词是不准确的，基于既有公开报道又由在司法部及其周围工作的人提供给我们的信息。
OK, do you guys have a card to play here with this like, "did you tell anybody" thing that Deutch was harping on?
所以看来他们知道一些事情，并试图抓住他做虚假陈述。那只鞋在六个小时里从未落下。没有“抓住你了”的时刻——我们知道你去年夏天做了什么，惠特克先生。相反，惠特克听证会后出现在新闻上的戏剧性时刻与纳德勒提出的问题无关。是这个。
Yes. I mean, it's not a card to play so much as we have reason to believe that his testimony is not accurate, based on information both publicly reported and delivered to us by people who work in and around the Department of Justice.
有没有人要求你批准特别检察官采取的任何请求或行动？
So it seems like they know something, and they're trying to catch him making a false statement. That shoe never drops the whole six hours. There is no gotcha moment-- we know what you did last summer, Mr. Whitaker. Instead, the dramatic moment that ends up on the news after the Whitaker hearing has nothing to do with the questions Nadler was asking. It was this.
主席先生，我看到你的五分钟结束了。所以……
Have you ever been asked to approve any request or action to be taken by the special counsel?
（观众惊呼）
Mr. Chairman, I see that your five minutes is up. And so--
这个让房间感到震惊的不体面的回答——如果你听说过听证会，那可能就是你听到的全部。杰里·纳德勒做出了杰里·纳德勒会做出的反应，笑了笑，继续前进。
[AUDIENCE EXCLAIMING]
在接下来的几个月里，我们将了解这些众议院委员会主席的不同风格——司法委员会的纳德勒，情报委员会的亚当·希夫，监督委员会的伊莱贾·卡明斯。他主持了迈克尔·科恩的听证会。卡明斯几乎是一个主持仪式的牧师。他知道如何吸引观众并留住他们。纳德勒，在他与惠特克的听证会上，处理的是一个非常不同的证人。但同样，他也是一个非常不同的主席。
This indecorous response that scandalized the room-- if you heard about the hearing, that's probably all you heard. Jerry Nadler responded how Jerry Nadler would, laughed it off and moved on.
花了几周观察他为这次听证会做准备，然后主持这次听证会，我认为公平地说，他不太喜欢听证会的剧场部分。他的脑子里有一个法律图书馆。他很务实。他临危不乱。他试图查明这里的一些事情。他不太关注观众的体验，他们的结论。
In the coming months, we're going to get to know the different styles of these House committee chairs-- Nadler in judiciary, Adam Schiff in the Intelligence Committee, Elijah Cummings in oversight. He ran the Michael Cohen hearing. Cummings is a master of ceremonies-type preacher almost. He knows how to reach an audience and hold it. Nadler, in his hearing with Whitaker, was dealt a very different witness. But also, he's a very different chairman.
事实是。我不明白——我不知道在听证会结束时我应该得到什么。作为一个等待已久的美国人，我不知道我应该怎么想。
After spending weeks watching him gear up for and then run this hearing, I think it's fair to say he's not so into the theater part of the hearing. He's got a law library in his head. He's practical. He's unflappable. He's trying to get to the bottom of something here. He's not so focused on the audience experience of it, their takeaway.
好吧，我们举行听证会不是为了让人们想些什么。
Here's the truth. I didn't understand-- I didn't know what I was supposed to get at the end of that hearing. I didn't know what I was supposed to think, as an American who's been waiting.
好的。
Well, we weren't doing the hearing in order to get people to think something.
对于未来的听证会可能确实如此。这次听证会的功能是确保我们自己，并延伸到美国人民，以确定穆勒调查是受阻还是在进行。这就是目的。
OK.
好的。那么根据那个标准，纳德勒和他的委员会做得怎么样？他们记录了六个小时的陈述，人们现在正在仔细研究。《纽约时报》和《华尔街日报》都发表报道称，根据他们的报道，惠特克在证词中撒了谎。
That may be true of future hearings. The function of this hearing was to assure ourselves, and by extension the American people, to determine whether the Mueller investigation was being hamstrung or going on. That was the purpose.
惠特克现在同意回到司法委员会，引用，“澄清他的证词”。所以那个记录将继续增长。建立记录很重要。从政府那里得到关于过去两年的明确答案很重要。但在某个时候，整体故事和观众对国会在这里所做的事情的理解可能会成为最大的事情。
OK. So by that measure, how did Nadler and his committee do? They got six hours of statements on the record that people are now poring over. The New York Times and The Wall Street Journal both published stories saying, according to their reporting, Whitaker lied during his testimony.
几个月前当很明显纳德勒将成为司法委员会主席时，就在中期选举之后，他被问到很多关于弹劾听证会的问题。他说，它们可能会撕裂这个国家。这是因为弹劾取决于公众舆论法庭。足够多的人是否看到了同样的事件以同样的方式？你能想象吗？我们离那个阶段还很远。
Whitaker's now agreed to come back to the Judiciary Committee to, quote, "clarify his testimony." So that record will continue to grow. Building a record matters. Getting clear answers from the administration about the last two years matters. But at some point, the overall story and the audience's understanding of what Congress is doing here could become the biggest thing.
佐伊·蔡斯，我们节目的制作人之一。接下来，当你期待的时候，有一些你绝对不会预料到的事情。那将在芝加哥公共广播电台一分钟后，当我们的节目继续时。
When it was clear a few months ago that Nadler was going to be chair of judiciary, right after the midterms, he was asked about impeachment hearings a lot. They could tear the country apart, he said. That's because impeachment depends on the court of public opinion. Do enough people see the same events in the same way? Can you imagine? We are a really long way from that.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，挣扎着爬出冰面。我们有关于人们在困难情况下试图移动的故事。他们试图修理东西。有一段时间，无论如何，他们是在原地踏步，只是尝试一个又一个战术，希望有东西会起作用。
Zoe Chace, who's one of the producers of our show. Coming up, something seriously you do not expect when you're expecting. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
我们已经到达我们节目的第二幕。第二幕，沉下去。所以这个下一个故事是关于一个在解决她面临的问题上有很多选择的人。我不认为夸大其词说她尝试了所有这些方法。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, scrambling to get off the ice. We have stories of people in difficult situations who are trying to move. They're trying to fix things. And for a while, anyway, they are running in place, just attempting one tactic after another, hoping something is going to work.
她的名字是杰西卡·霍珀。她是一位音乐记者，曾经在我们节目中帮我们处理音乐问题。这个故事是关于她和一位医生，以及性不当行为。换句话说，内容可能不适合每个人。
We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, Going Under. So this next story is about somebody who had a lot of options for fixing the problem that she faced. And I don't think it's an exaggeration to say she tried them all.
在我们开始之前，我会指出，故事中的医生否认任何不当行为，并且从一开始就坚定地否认它。事实上，当这出现在法官面前时，法官裁定没有足够的证据达到确立医生不当行为所需的标准，尽管他说他发现杰西卡的证词，引用，“情绪化且可信的”。他发现她可信。这里是杰西卡。
Her name is Jessica Hopper. She's a music journalist who used to help us here with the music on our show. And the story is about her and a doctor, and sexual misconduct. In other words, content that might not be right for everybody.
2012年3月1日，我在医院生我的儿子。一位麻醉师在给我注射硬膜外麻醉时反复猥亵我。我一遍又一遍地讲述了他对我所做的事情，在过去七年里几十次告诉医院、警察、侦探、我的律师、州医疗许可调查员、我的受害者倡导者、法官、记者、另一位侦探，最后是亲近我的人。这个故事变得更加精确，为了先发制人地应对我知道会来的问题。我可以用一种不间断的独白说出这一切。
And before we start, I will point out that the doctor in the story denies any wrongdoing and has steadfastly denied it from the start. In fact, when this got before a judge, the judge ruled that there was not enough proof to meet the standard necessary to establish misconduct on the doctor's part, though he said he found Jessica's testimony to be, quote, "emotional and believable." He found her credible. Here's Jessica.
我从这如何是我的第二个儿子开始，为什么我们选择了这家邻里医院。我提供了我丈夫开车送我去那里时我的心态，我有多警觉和清醒。我讲述了麻醉师如何要求我丈夫和导乐离开房间，他如何让我脱下长袍露出怀孕的肚子，他的过程如何有条不紊，但与我第一个儿子时的硬膜外麻醉完全不同。我追踪了医生如何在我的背上从一点到另一点运行一条注射线，一条细塑料管，并莫名其妙地把它贴在我的乳房之间。
On March 1, 2012, I was in the hospital delivering my son. And an anesthesiologist repeatedly groped me while administering my epidural. I've told the story of what he did to me again and again, dozens of times over the last seven years to the hospital, the police, the detectives, my attorney, the state medical licensing investigator, my victim advocate, a judge, a reporter, another detective, and eventually people close to me. The story's only become more precise in order to preempt the questions I know will come. I can speak it all in an unbroken monologue.
我精确地指出那一刻是我知道出事了，我是如何阅读他的名字标签并记下他的名字，他站在哪里，房间里的光在哪里，大约是什么时间。我详细说明了他如何把手放在我的乳房上，杯状并握住它们。我把这种触摸描述为性的而不是临床的。我描述了当我问，“你在做什么？”时，他是如何沉默的。以及他如何再次这样做。直到我说，“你在做什么鬼？”它才停止。我解释了他如何不看我，只是离开了房间，以及我丈夫回到房间后我是如何立即告诉他的。
I start with how this was my second son, why we chose this neighborhood hospital. I offer my state of mind as my husband drove me there, how alert and aware I was. I recount how the anesthesiologist asked my husband and my doula to leave the room, how he had me take my gown down over my pregnant belly, how his process was methodical, but entirely different than the epidural I got with my first son. I trace on my body how the doctor ran an injection line, a thin plastic tube, from a spot on my back and inexplicably taped it right between my breasts.
大约一个半小时后，在生下儿子后一两分钟内，我告诉了整个房间那个医生对我做了什么。但我告诉他们的方式既讽刺又紧张，几乎像是一个笑话，说我很高兴有硬膜外麻醉，以至于我几乎不在乎医生抚摸了我。我知道他们听到了我，因为称量我儿子的新生儿护士僵住了，其中一个锁定了我的眼睛。我的助产士告诉我，“不要那样说。那没发生。不要那样说。”
I pinpoint that moment as when I know something was off, how I read his name tag and took note of his name, where he stood, where the light was in the room, approximately what time of day. I detail how he put his hands on my breasts, cupped and held them. I describe the touch as sexual and not clinical. I describe how he was silent when I asked, what are you doing? And how he did it again. It did not stop until I said, what the [BLEEP] are you doing? I explain how he did not look at me and just left the room, how I told my husband immediately after he came back in the room.
这是故事中我的独白改变的部分。它变成了我告诉谁以及如何告诉谁的诉状，我如何在我手机上设置提醒警报。至少一周一次，在我孩子的午睡期间，我会打电话给医院，试图告诉某人发生了什么，试图导航到正确的语音信箱，医院行政人员、人力资源、接待员、病人倡导者。我打了几个星期的电话，直到有人记下了我的陈述。我很快收到了一封来自医院的信，告诉我他们调查了，我的陈述是“未经证实的”。
About an hour and a half later, within a minute or two of delivering my son, I told the entire room what the doctor had done to me. But how I told them came out sarcastic and nervous, almost like a joke, saying that I was so happy to have an epidural that I almost didn't mind that the doctor had felt me up. I knew they heard me because the neonatal nurses weighing my son froze, and one locked eyes with me. My midwife told me, don't say that. That didn't happen. Don't say that.
我在州医疗许可委员会在线提交了一份投诉。我只是想阻止这种情况发生在任何人身上。我报了警。几周后，我和一位友好的侦探做了几次长时间的采访。在被告知没有人相信我几个月后，他的关心和照顾感觉很有意义。
This is the part in the story where my monologue changes. It becomes a litany of who I told and how, how I set a reminder alarm on my phone. And at least once a week during my children's nap time, I would call the hospital to try to tell someone what happened, to try to navigate to the right voicemail, the hospital administrators, HR, the receptionist, the patient advocate. I called for weeks until someone took down my account. I soon got a letter from the hospital, telling me that they'd looked into it and that my account was unsubstantiated.
几周后，一位新侦探被指派到我的案件中。我又重新开始了，在一年多的时间里反复讲述这个故事。新侦探会定期向我更新我案件的进展。他们是戏剧性的故事，让他和另一个警察听起来像牛仔。
I filed a complaint online with the state medical licensing board. I just wanted to stop this from happening to anyone else. I filed a police report. A few weeks later, I did several long interviews with a nice detective. His concern and care felt meaningful after months of being told that no one believed me.
他告诉我他们去了医院采访医生，被医院员工挡住了。他告诉我当他们拿着搜查令回去时，医生已经逃离了这个国家。他告诉我他们发布了一份国际逮捕令并追踪了他。他告诉我他们去了医生的郊区豪宅，在圣诞节早晨逮捕了他，现在医生害怕了。我开始怀疑侦探告诉我的话。
A few weeks later, a new detective was assigned to my case. And I started over, retelling the story several times over the course of a year. The new detective would periodically update me with progress on my case. They were dramatic stories, made him and the other cop sound like cowboys.
几个月后，侦探让我去县法院旁边的购物中心见他。他让我坐在Sephora对面的一张玻璃桌旁，告诉我州检察官拒绝接手这个案子，甚至不提出指控，因为他说，“她说，他她说”的案子是不可能起诉的。他敦促我放弃这个案子，继续我的生活。他说那个医生可能已经害怕得停止了。
He told me they had gone to the hospital to interview the doctor, and they'd been blocked by hospital staff. He told me when they went back with a warrant, the doctor had fled the country. He told me that they put out an international APB on him and had tracked him. He told me that they had gone to the doctor's suburban mansion and arrested him at dawn on Christmas morning, and now the doctor was scared. I had started to doubt what the detective was telling me.
在经历了18个月狂野的故事和没有指控后，和侦探坐在商场里，我有一种沉入谷底的感觉，这是一种表演——告诉我正义已经耗尽，希望我会相信，这样他就可以合上我的档案，称之为一天。我意识到我需要转换战术。我离开了会议，给一位律师朋友打了电话，他介绍我认识了一位愿意帮我免费提起民事诉讼的律师。
A few months later, the detective had me meet him in person at the shopping center by the county courthouse. He sat me down at a glass table across from a Sephora and told me that the state's attorney was declining to take the case or even bring charges because he said, she said cases were impossible to prosecute. He urged me to give up on the case and go on with my life. He said that the doctor was probably scared enough that he had stopped.
几个月后，这位律师为我列出了一些选择，但他随后跟上了侦探所说的话。这是我与医生的对抗。在这样的案子中，好的结果很少见，他看到过受害者在另一边被摧毁。我知道那是真的，我相信他告诉我的话。
Sitting there in the mall with the detective after 18 months of wild stories and no charges, I had the sinking feeling that this was a performance of some sort-- telling me that justice had been exhausted and hoping I would believe it so he could close up my case file and call it a day. I realized I needed to switch tactics. I left the meeting and called a lawyer friend who referred me to an attorney who was willing to help me bring a civil case pro bono.
我觉得除非我有这件事发生的视频，否则我不会被相信。但我希望医生面临后果。医生所做的事情让我充满了恐惧和焦虑。我对他人的触摸感到焦虑。结果，自从生下儿子后，我已经几年没看医生或牙医了。
After a few months, this lawyer laid out some options for me, but then he followed that with exactly what the detective had said. It was my word against the doctor. And with cases like this, good outcomes were rare, that he had seen victims come out the other side destroyed. I knew that was true, and I trusted what he was telling me.
这个医生在应该安全的环境中做了什么，在我在最脆弱的时候，在分娩时——之后，我怎么能信任任何人？我觉得不安全。我做噩梦。我感到羞耻，不是为了医生所做的，而是我可能可以做些不同的事情，这样其他人会更认真地对待这一点。
I felt like unless I had video of this happening, I wouldn't be believed. But I wanted the doctor to face consequences. What the doctor had done had filled me with fear and anxiety. I was anxious about being touched. As a result, I hadn't seen a doctor or dentist in years since delivering my son.
我的律师说如果我愿意，他会进行这个案子，但他建议我继续前进，专注于我生活中的好事，我的家人，我的职业。他向我保证，如果曾经有其他人挺身而出，我的民事投诉将会在那里支持他们的陈述。2015年情人节，感觉非常灰心，我告诉我的律师放弃我的案子。我没有谈论它或告诉朋友或家人，因为我只是想这一切消失。我试图忘记，但我不能。
What this doctor did in this setting that's supposed to be safe, where I was at my most vulnerable, in labor-- after that, how could I trust anyone? I didn't feel safe. I had nightmares. And I felt shame, not for what the doctor had done, but that maybe I could have done something differently, so others would have taken this more seriously.
2017年12月，我正在家里折叠衣服，接到了州许可委员会一名调查员的电话。她说她是这个职位的新手，只是在跟进她前任悬而未决的案子，我愿意和她谈谈吗？已经五年了。我是矛盾和愤世嫉俗的。
My attorney said he would pursue the case if I wanted, but he suggested I move on and focus on the good things in my life, my family, my career. He assured me that if anyone else ever came forward, that my civil complaint would be there to bolster their account. On Valentine's Day 2015, feeling deeply discouraged, I told my lawyer to drop my case. I didn't talk about it or tell friends or family because I just wanted this all to go away. I tried to forget, but I couldn't.
她让我签署一份发布文件，这样她就可以得到我的医疗记录。我没有费心。我觉得再经历一次没有用，而且假装不是这样很痛苦。几周后她又打来电话，问我是否愿意告诉她我的故事。在一个小时的过程中，我做了，但我肯定再次讲述这个故事没有用。我不再相信任何人能帮助我或阻止他。
In December 2017, I was at home and folding laundry when I got a call from an investigator with the state licensing board. She said she was new to the position and was just following up on her predecessor's open cases, and would I be willing to talk to her? It'd been five years. I was ambivalent and cynical.
2018年2月，调查员给我打电话，告诉我我的案子有了进展。另一个受害者挺身而出，提出了几乎相同的要求。她工作的一名检察官说如果我签署同意书发布我的医疗记录，他们可以对医生的执照进行紧急停职，这将阻止他执业。我说是的。
She asked me to sign a release so she could get my medical records. I didn't bother. I felt like there was no use in going through this again, and it was painful to pretend otherwise. She called again a few weeks later and asked me if I would tell her my story. Over the course of an hour, I did, but I was certain there was no use telling the story again. I no longer believed anyone could help me or stop him.
他问我是否愿意出庭指控医生。我说是的。最后，我被相信了，因为我们有两个人。我挂了电话，在倒塌在地板上哭泣之前，不自觉地尖叫了一遍又一遍。我很愤怒我们现在有两个人。我很兴奋我们现在有两个人。我们并不孤单。
In February 2018, the investigator called me and told me that there was a development in my case. Another victim had come forward with an almost identical claim. A prosecutor she worked with said if I signed consent forms to release my medical records, they could file an emergency suspension of the doctor's license that would stop him from practicing. I said yes.
关于那个挺身而出的女人，我所了解到的是她没有证件，是一个单身母亲。她不太会英语，她在作证。我感到被爱和感激所淹没，为她，我不认识的勇敢女人，冒着风险挺身而出的女人。
He asked me if I would be willing to testify against the doctor. I said yes. Finally, I was being believed because there were two of us. I got off the phone and involuntary screamed over and over before collapsing on the floor, sobbing. I was furious there were now two of us. I was elated there were now two of us. We were not in this alone.
州医疗许可委员会正在推动医生的执照停职。我见了两位检察官准备作证。他们只有几天时间。在此期间，我发现最初指派给我的侦探，包括告诉我他逮捕了医生的侦探，在商场见我的侦探，他在担任我案子的近两年里从没有做过任何笔记，在他采访我的所有时间里一次也没有。他从没有采访或逮捕医生。他从没有把我的案子带给州检察官。他只是坐在它上面。
What I'd learned about the woman who'd come forward was that she was undocumented, a single mom. She did not speak much English, and she was testifying. I felt overcome with love and gratitude for her, this brave woman I didn't know, this woman who is taking a risk coming forward.
我发现我对许可委员会的最初投诉在没有调查的情况下被驳回了，因为我拼错了医生的姓。国家监管机构意识到我案子的第一次是在2015年夏天，在我放弃之后。我所做的一切，所有所谓的追求的正确步骤，结果都一事无成。齿轮从没咬合。
The state medical licensing board was moving for the suspension of the doctor's license. I met with two prosecutors to prepare to testify. They only had a few days. During this, I found out that the detectives initially assigned to my case, including the detective who had told me he'd arrested the doctor, the detective who had met me at the mall, he had never made any notes during the nearly two years he'd been on my case, not once in all the times he had interviewed me. He never interviewed or arrested the doctor. He never brought my case to the state's attorney. He just sat on it.
许可委员会的检察官不停地道歉，不断地。他们说他们多年前本可以尝试起诉医生的。听证会发生在去年六月。医生作证说他无罪，并带了一个裸体人体模型到听证室进行演示。助产士也作证了，承认在产房里说了，“不要那样说”，尽管她否认曾经对我说，“那没发生”。
I found out that my initial complaint to the licensing board had been dismissed without investigation because I had misspelled the doctor's last name. The first time the state regulators became aware of my case was in the summer of 2015, after I had dropped it. Everything I had done, all the so-called right steps to pursue, had amounted to nothing. The cogs had never caught.
其他人，那个挺身而出的人，她整个上午都在作证。我在她之后作证。我们没有见面。我必须识别那个虐待我的医生。他坐在我后面。我不会错过他。
The licensing board prosecutors apologized profusely, continually. They said they could have tried to prosecute the doctor years ago. The hearing happened last June. The doctor testified he was not guilty and brought a naked mannequin to the hearing room for purposes of demonstration. The midwife testified too, admitted to saying in the delivery room, don't say that, though she denied ever saying to me, that didn't happen.
医生的辩护律师试图暗示这一切都是我丈夫策划的诡计，我声称被殴打是为了试图从医院获得赔偿。医生的辩护律师问我为什么，如果这如此具有破坏性，为什么我没告诉别人？为什么我没寻求帮助？我试图解释我只是想让这一切消失。
The other women, the one who came forward, she testified all morning. And I testified after her. We did not meet. I had to ID the doctor who victimized me. He was sitting behind me. I couldn't miss him.
当时我没能解释清楚的是我不想应对任何人的反应。我不想想别人是否相信我。我不想让任何人感到为我遗憾。
The doctor's defense attorneys tried to suggest this was all a ploy cooked up by my husband, that I had claimed being assaulted in order to try to get a settlement from the hospital. The doctor's defense attorney asked me why, if this was so devastating, why hadn't I told people? Why hadn't I gotten help? I tried to explain that I just wanted this to go away.
他们问我关于时间表。他们试图绊倒我。没用。检察官告诉我我做得很好。我离开听证会时很疲惫，但我感到非常轻松。我觉得我要飘走了。我觉得没什么我做不到的。我觉得自己像神奇女侠，像当她用一只手举起汽车时。我想到了那个女人。我想知道她感觉如何。我想知道她是否也感觉一样。
What I didn't understand well enough to explain at the time was that I didn't want to deal with anyone's reactions. I didn't want to wonder if another person believed me. I didn't want anyone to feel sorry for me.
杰西卡·霍珀。故事中的医生，他的医疗执照被无限期停职，至少三年。因为他对那个女人所做的事情，他被罚款15,000美元。他没有因为与杰西卡有关的任何事情受到纪律处分，因为她的要求没有足够的证据。
They asked me about timelines. They tried to trip me up. It didn't work. The prosecutors told me I'd done well. I left the hearing exhausted, but I felt so light. I felt like I was going to float away. I felt like there was nothing I couldn't do. I felt like Wonder Woman, like when she lifts a car with a single hand. I thought about the other woman. I wondered how she felt. I wondered if she felt the same.
我们联系他征求意见，他的律师发给我们一份单句声明，否认任何不当行为，并指出医生正在对他的停职提出上诉。我们还联系了杰西卡说在商场见到她的侦探以及他上面的调查负责人。都没有回应。
Jessica Hopper. The doctor in her story, his medical license was suspended with an indefinite suspension for a minimum of three years. And he was fined $15,000 for what he did to the other woman. He was not disciplined for anything relating to Jessica because there wasn't enough proof for her claims.
我们的节目今天由罗宾·塞米恩制作。今天组织我们节目的人包括埃尔娜·贝克、佐伊·蔡斯、阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德、尼尔·德拉明、希拉里·埃尔金斯、贾瑞特·弗洛伊德、达米安·格拉夫、塞思·林德、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷蒙多、本·费伦、纳迪亚·雷曼、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、南希·厄普代克、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。我们的管理编辑是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆。
We approached him for comment, and his lawyer sent us a one-sentence statement denying any wrongdoing and pointing out that the doctor is in the process of appealing his suspension. We also reached out to the detective who Jessica says met with her at the mall and the head of investigations above him. Neither responded.
今天特别感谢杰西卡·安德鲁斯、美国监督组织的约翰·比斯、凯特·布兰南、巴里·哈迪蒙、史蒂夫·利克蒂格、凯莱法·桑内、本·特里斯、安迪·赖特和马克·罗泽尔。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们超过600集的档案。或者使用《美国生活》应用程序下载我们的节目。
Our program was produced today by Robin Semien. The people who put our show together today includes Elna Baker, Zoe Chace, Aviva DeKornfeld, Neil Drumming, Hilary Elkins, Jarrett Floyd, Damien Graef, Seth Lind, Stowe Nelson, Catherine Raimondo, Ben Phelan, Nadia Reiman, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is David Kestenbaum.
《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交流中心交付给公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，他和他的朋友们一直怀疑我是怎么主持这个节目的。
Special thanks today to Jessica Andrews, John Bies at American Oversight, Kate Brannan, Barrie Hardymon, Steve Licktieg, Kelefa Sanneh, Ben Terris, Andy Wright, and Mark Rozell. Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our archive of over 600 episodes for absolutely free. Or download our shows, using This American Life app.
我们都怀疑他被放在那里只有一个原因，而且是唯一的原因，那就是干扰穆勒调查。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he and his friends have always had suspicions about how I got to host this show.
我既不会证实也不会否认。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再见，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
We all suspect he was put there for one reason and one reason only, to interfere with the Mueller investigation.
我们都怀疑他被安插在那里只有一个目的，那就是干扰穆勒调查。
I will neither confirm nor deny. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我既不证实也不否认。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周同一时间，我们将带来更多《美国生活》的故事。